[Musique]
tour sa place
jeanjoress ses étudiants son ouverture
sur la
Loire et 350000 habitants dans la
métropole qui comme partout jettent
leurs déchets non
recyclables des déchets entéré
inexorablement depuis bientôt 40
ans aujourd'hui n'existe aucune solution
alors que l'enfouissement sera bientôt
interdit mais comment en est-on arrivé
[Musique]
là le spectacle est désolant des
centaines de milliers de tonnes de
déchets enfouis et promises aux
générations
[Musique]
futures
les déchets sont poussés par les engins
qui sont derrière moi et ils sont
compactés dans le casier qui est à votre
gauche on consomme on consomme et puis
après ben j'irai on jette et
malheureusement c'est vrai Mo derrière
nous on voit on voit de l'énergie il y a
un potentiel qui qui qui est là hein il
y a des choses qui sont faites on peut
encore faire
plus situé à 22 km de tour cette
décharge a été choisie par Jean Royet
ancien maire de la ville au milieu des
années
80 un immense site de 85 haectares pour
engloutir les ordur ménagères non
recyclable le meilleur déchet c'est
celui qui n'existe pas et recyclons au
maximum réutilisons au maximum
valorisons au maximum réservons j'
dirais vraiment l'ultime ce qu'on peut
pas je dirais valoriser trier pour ce
type
[Musique]
d'installation à 30 km de là la commune
de parcémelllé tente de conserver son
caractère rural et vtic
colle Jean-Marc gilet ouille le vin pour
chasser l'air des
bariques on complète après c'est souvent
plus les bar bonour char ça va oui
destiné à faire ma cuvée cette cuve
là vient despendre de Fran et on a aussi
les enfors qui sont à côté et qui vont
être vigifiés de la même façon ça fait
1700 ans qu'il y a des vignes sur
l'appellation vousouvrai c'est
Saint-Martin qui l'a apporté et c'est
toute une histoire c'est tout c'est
c'est pas qu'une génération c'est des
générations viticulteur de père en fils
Jean-Marc gilet et Charles Thomas se
sont batttu l'été dernier contre le
projet
d'incinérateur avec déjà deux autoroutes
un aéroport et une zone industrielle de
200 hactar c'était pour eux le projet de
trop on a toujours envie de défendre nos
terroirs et surtout les terroirs de
l'appellation en
général on est aussi issu de deux
familles historiques vigneron donc ça
fait plusieurs générations que qu'on est
ici entre
guillemets mon grand-père il nous en par
enfin il m'en parlait déjà à l'époque et
mon père aussi nous nous en a parlé mais
la mise en place de de plein de choses
qui ont déjà été faites dans le passé
qui on un petit peu entaché l'image de
l'appellation l'image de la commune et
surtout l'image agricole et viticole
c'est c'est des choses qu'on étit un peu
un peu embêtant on n pas envie de on a
vraiment pas envie de revivre ça
maintenant quoi aujourd'hui on ne parle
plus d'incinérateur mais Duve unité de
valorisation
énergétique si la terminologie a bien
changé son image négative persiste la
métropole dit souvent que c'est le
poumon vert de de la métropole par C
roche Corbon ben on justement on est là
pour garder cette image là et et de pas
avoir du Ve après effectivement ça fait
20 ans que on cherche un endroit pour
l've mais politiquement ils ont jamais
trouvé d'accord ils ont ils se sont
jamais vraiment je pense penchés sur la
question et personne en veut et
effectivement par s ml non plus nen veut
pas personne n'en veut et c'est bien là
le problème en 20 ans t lesjets
d'incinérateur ont été enterrés les uns
après les autres jou les tours
Saint-Pierre DESC ne pompière subl ma ou
encore ballonm à chaque fois la même
opposition pour la même issue d'une
certaine manière nous avons probablement
écarté la perspective deincinérateur
d'au moins 3 ou 4 ans et nous l'espérons
de façon définitive à cette époque pour
les écologistes lesets générateurs sont
trop polluants leur solution réduire les
déchets et promouvoir le tri alors ce
n'est pas grave si les déchets
continuent de prendre la route pour être
enterré à son
[Musique]
Z en ce lundi matin Jean-Luc Gallot
entame sa tournée
quotidienne un petit rituel avec y son
chien j'ai même trouvé des tests de
grossesse un matin mais pas encore
billet de
banque le zéro déchet ça reste encore un
fantasme quand on on voit tout ce qu'on
peut ramasser un petit tour le matin
avec son
animal l'ancien président de Touren
propre le gestionnaire des déchets de
l'agglomération tourangel a passé une
très grande partie de sa vie à gérer le
dossier poubelle pour en finir avec
l'enfouissement des ordures
ménagères mes amis avaient l'habitude de
dire que j'étais un homme de dossier et
effectivement je j'aimais beaucoup
travailler et surtout
essayer de
comprendre tous les élus d'indrloir
étaient favorabl à ce projet qui était
inscrit dans le plan départemental en
2003 2004 on était prêt nous avions fait
toutes les études financières juridiques
on avait travaillé sur le
dimensionnement du projet on avait
confié une étude à é au France pour voir
les retomber des
éventuels impacts bref la situation
était très avancée et puis il y a comme
partout des minorités agissantes on le
voit un peu partout en France dès qu'un
projet apparaît on est confronté à des
oppositions de plus en plus intégristes
qui qui s'opposent à tout et donc les
politiques confrontés à des problèmes de
réélection ont plutôt tendance à à
reculer face à
l'obstacle si la métropole de tour enfou
donc toujours ses déchets elle doit
remercier les écologistes en 2004 c'est
eux qui font capoter le projet dans le
cadre d'accords
pré-électoraux évidemment il y a eu sans
doute autour de ça des des des des
situations politiques mais je crois que
par exemple quand il a été décidé un
moratoire sur l'incinérateur c'était un
accord programmatique c'était pas un
accord de cointable comme j'ai pu
l'entendre ça a été des années de
discussion pour arriver à ça en se
disant quelles sont les altern
mais il fallait mettre en uvre les
alternatives elles n'ont pas été mises
en œuvre aujourd'hui nous sommes au pied
du mur 20 ans après les mêmes qui
étaient farouchementosé veulent
aujourd'hui une unité de valorisation
énergétique in comble mais Charles
Fournier s'en défend les ver voulent
n'en voulit pas mais voulit une
politique de prévention pendant 20 ans
qui n'a pas été mis en œuvre vouleit une
réduction des déchets vouleit une
interdiction du plastique vouleit que
nous sortions d'une logique économique
qui nous conduit à produire des déchets
voulait l'économie circulaire tout ça
n'a pas été fait nous sommes dans la
situation aujourd'hui nous devons
accepter cette solution tout en disant
elle do ne doit pas durer dans le
temps aujourd'hui la métropole de tour
se retrouve donc au pied du mur pour
plusieurs raisons le site de sonzé
arrive à saturation et la loi de 2015
sur la transition énergétique oblige ces
sites d'enfouissement à
fermer sur les 74000 tonnes d'ordure
ménagère généré par les tours rangeau
chaque année 16 % prennent l'autoroute à
10 pour aller se faire incinérer à
Blois et demain un nouvel accord prévoit
que 25000 tonnes iront dans le mellloir
àass à 65 km à tour les ordures
ménagères c'est bien chez les
autres pour Benoît pierre élu à la
métropole et anciennement en charge du
dossier poubelle vous étiez autour de
cette situation est
révoltante ça veut dire des camions qui
vont être mis sur la route et ça ça ne
pose pas de problème non seulement au
vice-président qui est en charge de la
question mais aussi de la majorité de de
tour qui est une majorité écologiste
donc il y a encore après 30 années de
débat de tergiversation d'hésitation de
retournement de situation on en est
aujourd'hui quasiment à un point0 et ça
je trouve ça totalement
dommageable son de cloche évidemment à
la présidence actuelle de la métropole
selon Martin Cohen la situation est
certes critique mais elle présenterait
paradoxalement un avantage il y a 10 15
ans on était sur 150000 tonnes on sera à
60000 tonnes aujourd'hui la prévention s
poursuivie on sent que ça prend ça
commence à rentrer bien dans dans les
consciences des des concitoyens donc
finalement d'avoir attendu une dizaine
d'années ça nous permet de dimensionner
aujourd'hui un outil de façon beaucoup
plus petite beaucoup mieux dimensionné
finalement et donc d'avoir fait avancer
cette politique de prévention c'est le
premier avantage le deuxième avantage
d'être aussi au pied du mur c'est que on
est sur des technologies aujourd'hui qui
sont vraiment à la pointe sur les
filtrations et donc on va être sur un
outil qui est beaucoup plus propre que
ce qu'on aurait pu construire dans les
toutes premières dans toutes les tout
toutes premières tentatives dans les
années
90 reste à savoir où sera construite
l'unité de valorisation énergétique
dimensionnée au besoins
actuels retour sur le site
d'enfouissement de sonzé volontaire pour
accueillir l'incinérateur un site
habitué d'ailleurs à gérer les déchets
et même à les
valoriser ici suè récupère 40 % du
méthane émis par les déchets pour
produire de
l'électricité on est raccordé au réseau
d'énéis et donc et bien on a à peu près
les besoins de 9000 foyer hor chauffage
qui sont couverts tous les ans par la
production du site c'est 23 GWh pour
donner quelques
chiffres dans le village situé à 3 km du
site d'enfouissement le sujet n'est pas
un problème depuis longtemps les
habitants s'en
accommode en tout cas au quotidien c'est
pas notre sujet de réflexion et c'est
pas notre sujet de trac
quoi aux affaires depuis une quinzaine
d'années le maire Jean-Pierre vernaau en
a vu d'autres loin de la métropole ce
petit village de 1400 habitants absorbe
comme si de rien nétait les centaines de
milliers de tonnes d'ordure tout r
comment vas-tu ça va pas trop mal
ouiou c'est ton remplaçant alors ah non
non
non le patron pour le maire s est le
candidat naturel pour accueillir
l'équipement de traitement des déchets
l'unité de valorisation
énergétique
on n pas changé d'avis on est toujours
volontaire pour recevoir cette unité du
Ve pour un complément on a déjà donc le
centre d'enfouissement et je vois pas
pour quelle raison on serait pas
candidat encore aujourd'hui à continuer
à recevoir les déchets ménager comme on
les recevait jusqu'à actuellement après
qu décennies de bons et Loyau services
Jean-Pierre vernaau ne digère pas le
traitement réservé à sa commune
aujourd'hui je sais pas qu'il y a un
projet je sais pas un projet parce qu'on
a jamais été associé aux discussions
quoi que ce soit c'est par les médias
qu'on apprend que son Z pourrait être le
plan B quoi que ce soit mais c'est la
presque qui me la
prend seul inconvénient avec son Z il ne
permettrait pas d'utiliser la chaleur
produite pour alimenter en eau chaude
des bâtiments publics de tour trop
éloignés le dernier scénario envisagé
par la métropole pourrait être
l'aéroport de tour mais là encore le
dossier s'annonce très incertain
bien sûr chacun a ses raisons mais
queles que soient les explications des
uns et des autres la gestion des ordure
ménagère aura été au fil des décennies à
tour
consternante